women are the most resilient creatures
on the planet we're unstoppable
we're so powerful and we can truly do
anything we set our mind to
hey glamour uk i'm vanessa hudgens and
welcome to my unfiltered
i would never want to be a royal
the idea of it the chic-ness of it it's
cute but like the reality i'm just way
too goofy and
i
enjoy living my life to the fullest the
giving back aspect of it i think is
really beautiful
to be able to make such a significant
change and that's something that i try
to incorporate into my everyday life and
my legacy just working with
organizations but
yeah the day-to-day of it all i mean
i guess i already am under scrutiny
being someone who is in front of the
camera but the royals have it on a whole
other level i this is
not for me
i grew up loving
all the disney fairy tales the
princesses i mean they were musicals
come on of course i'm gonna love them um
but i i never really
believed that i needed a man in order to
have all my dreams come true um
that
wasn't my takeaway my takeaway from
those films were
life can be magical and there can be
synchronicities that push you from one
place into another and adversity you may
face will push you into your destiny and
you're probably gonna sing about it
along the way
feminism to me means being able to do
whatever the hell it is that you want to
do and
be supported
we should have equal rights we should
have equal pay we should all be treated
equally and to me it's about coming
forward and supporting each other it's
lifting other women up so that we can
achieve all the things that we want to
do and the more that we can lift each
other up the more support we have
there's power in numbers
you got to take care of yourself it's
easy to spread yourself in a million
different directions but at the end of
the day you are left to deal with
yourself so you have to make sure that
you are taking the appropriate steps to
feel that you are taken care of and for
me there's a lot of different things
that i do let go of work let go of any
distractions and just being present with
people who i love and who love me very
important
skin care is a big thing for me i i feel
like it's really nice just at the end of
the day and in the morning to have a
moment with yourself in the mirror and
know that you're taking time out of your
day for yourself to love on yourself and
and know that you're doing something
good for yourself
that's always just a really connecting
and grounding moment for me
my dad passed away the night before
grace live
and there was never a moment where i
thought that i wouldn't do it
because
my dad would want me to do it he gave so
much time
and energy
into me achieving my dreams and for me
to have a career where i can do what i
love and shine to honor him
to me that's what made it really special
knowing that i was kind of doing it in
honor of him
just made me feel even more connected to
him
if anything it just attests to
my tenacity
and resilience because women are the
most resilient creatures on the planet
and if we tap into that we're
unstoppable
we're so powerful we can truly do
anything we set our mind
to it's hard to say when i feel the most
myself because myself is so many
different things there's the version of
myself that is the most comfortable
at home in my pajamas with my
girlfriends stuff in a glass of wine
skipping around listening to music but
then there's another version of myself
that feels my most
my most me when i am done to the nines
and my face is beat my hair is snatched
and i've got a dress on that is ready to
stop traffic the through line is my
playfulness um i feel like i i
have a very
youthful spirit
um and
i think that in my younger years i tried
to fight that because when you're
younger you want to be older you want to
be taken seriously um and the older that
i get the more i realize it's so
important to keep that inner child alive
and to really
celebrate your inner youth and
to not push that down to really allow
that to
sparkle
i remember coming to set and meeting
holly hunter there and just kind of in
shock and looking around like
this is this is actually happening like
i'm working with someone who is
phenomenal such an amazing actress um i
was just elated
i love doing musicals growing up doing
musicals was my safe space it's what got
me out of my shell and i feel like i
really just have the most fond memories
of being in rehearsals and performing
when i'm performing i am in heaven
you know my mom is from the philippines
and she came out to the states when she
was 25 and had me and
and
i just feel like watching films growing
up there weren't really that many women
who looked like me and my mom and my
family and
it's just so important to share all the
different stories because
like we are a massive melting pot
to me dealing with disappointment is
something that i have had to do at such
an early age just growing up in the
industry you are going to be told no way
more than you are told yes and that's
just something that you have to deal
with
and my outlook on it ever since i was
young was the next thing that comes
along will be bigger and better um and i
truly believe in divine timing
and the power of manifestation the power
of being very poignant and direct about
what it is that you want and asking for
it and having faith that it will come
your way
even if it doesn't come immediately it
will come to you maybe not in the way
you expect it but it will arrive
when i find myself not getting what i
want
um
i tried to shift my perspective because
our perspective is the one thing that we
can control um and say i didn't get a
job that i really wanted i'm like well
that's okay because then i'll have more
time to focus on myself and like work on
something that i can dream up of myself
and just having faith that like it
wasn't meant to be um and then call all
my friends together community for me is
so important i think we
need others to lean on and it's okay to
ask for help and it's okay to
cry on someone's shoulder that's what
friends are for
i feel very empowered knowing
that
i am i'm working on things and and
spending my time and energy
going into things that i'm really
passionate and proud of sharing things
that i love with others feels very
empowering and being
supported by people i respect
and love is very empowering
and i think it's always just so
important to lift other people up i
think always just lift each other up
and and spread kindness because that in
itself is empowering knowing that you
can make someone's day better um
that's that's beautiful that's powerful
i feel like i've lived many many lives
um
just because i've been in this industry
for so long um you know as human beings
were always evolving and growing and
changing and i look back at the girl who
would just had big dreams and was so
excited and bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
and i look at where i am now and the
journey has been
all over the map um
you know i think it takes time to get
comfortable with yourself i think that
now i'm at a place where i have peace in
the unknown
i have peace in
feeling uprooted and not settled
anywhere
and it's the most freeing thing ever and
there's so much power within that
because i think it allows me to really
just be present in every moment and to
make the best out of every moment
because
this moment is all we really have so
yeah
[Music]
you